we are back with B Yang
everybody sometimes we talk about our
obsessions on this show but while we're
obsessed with many things there are also
things we're just not into um and which
B knows because he also talks about
things on his podcast L cult racist
which we've been talking about I love it
so much uh so today in honor of Bowen
it's time for a round of Kelly and Bowen
can't stand
it Kelly and Bowen can't stand it
very specific I like it I like it okay
here's how it works um we're going to
hit I feel like we should sing that next
time it we'll we'll hit the button and
our supercomputer will search through
our text messages for the things that
bother us most I know watch out uh then
bow or I will get we're gonna get to
vent about that topic so I'm gonna start
here we
go
litter go we don't mess around around
with that y'all like you just don't
Litter it's we don't play that why why
why yeah it drives me nuts I get very
angry okay you're going to be a perfect
New Yorker I this is amazing to but you
better not let me catch you I will Mama
will go off I will it it is something
that drives me insane it does it bother
you of course it it's and it's New York
there there is a trash can on every
corner basically ex like there's no
excuse you're right buy it yeah yeah
come on it'll literally be in front of
it and I'm like are you freaking kidding
me yeah this is actually so refreshing
cuz I saw that that word litter I
thought you were going to talk about
kitty
[Laughter]
litter I'm allergic to cats yeah there
you go okay it's your turn wow
okay uh cough drops wait what they don't
work no they don't get down there
they're just kind of clicking and
clacking around the teeth it's not
getting to the throat it's not medicine
it's not candy what are you pickling
what are you no way
wait I have the cough drops for you
Brothers pases no no that's the vocalist
thing to do no but no I love their
thieves and they're um it's the cough
ones you know what it does if you if you
have a cola it opens up your sinus cut
it's very I'm telling you you're going
to love them oh so have I been just
getting it wrong this whole time you've
been you've been buying the wrong ones
I've been buying the wrong ones and I'm
thinking they're supposed to go down but
they're supposed to go up no they're
supposed to like just help out overall
it will help clear out your throat I
literally in Vegas sometimes I live with
them in my mouth sometimes I've I've
choked on on but I don't care because
because it opens up your cat it's nice
if that's the way you go if you choke on
one of these then I'll hate them even
more I'm not going to like them I'm
going to hate them anymore okay wait I'm
going to I'm going to hit I'm going to
get you some
okay this is childhood trauma right here
I I it's I can't I will read a page a
thousand I can read fast actually I love
speed reading and not as fast as my
mother I'm like did you read it anyway
but like but I love it but I if some
someone's watching me I can't I read the
same page over and I'm like was I
reading it fast enough do you think they
like like I am so self-conscious if I
can't have people watch me read it's VY
it's not like a teleprompter I mean like
if I'm reading like a book or like if
I'm reading a script and I get nervous
about people watching me read right no
you might as well be on the toilet it's
it's so vulnerable which I do read a lot
yes it's a perfect place to read but it
is like it's where I check my emails yes
perfect place s
but it's it's you're so in the zone when
you read that like like my my jaw is
probably like like a g like I don't want
people looking at me I just get nervous
like kid at the chalkboard you know oh
come on it's sad it's fine okay one more
I one more okay here we
go let's see baby's breath wait what the
flowers not breath from a
baby
okay but I'm going to I'm going to take
this opportunity to drag baby babies
like actual breath of babies as
well they're the most pathetic Little
Flower they they don't do anything they
don't add anything well and why are we
calling flowers that because have you
smelled a baby's
breath not great I don't know I I have a
thing with babies I do love babies like
they're bre I do puppy breath like I
love all that oh I do I guess I guess
I'm just a bad person yeah no you're not
you just I just like weird smelling
things apparently no I do but I like the
language of flowers I'm very into that
and so I like that it represent like who
I don't usually put it in a in a bouquet
often because um it represents like you
know innocence and Purity and I don't
know a lot of those people so all right
that is Kelly and Bowen can't stand it
um but you're welcome we have moved just
so many people with that Bowen's movie
is called dicks the musical it's in
theater sty just like saying it and
tomorrow night you can catch a brand new
SNL on NBC and peacock with host and
musical guest Bad
[Music]
[Applause]
Bunny here guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home